Hey folks.
Thank you for getting the numbers in by
midnight. Almost all of you did, a few
came in this morning, but I think
we're pretty much at full capacity in
terms of everybody
in terms of everybody Can you hear my
mic now?
So, what I'm going to do is actually
take your numbers and use it as a way of
looking back at the entire class. We've
covered a lot of stuff, but your project
gives us a way kind of spanning all of
those things.
Now, at the start of the semester
I told you that I don't use cases.
And the reason is actually in your
hands. Each of you is working on a live
case. The problem with live cases you
don't know how it'll end. So, it's not
quite ended. It's it's in pause. You've
done it up till now.
But things will keep coming at you,
which I think makes it exciting, but it
also makes it unsettling.
So, let's start with with something that
I'm sure all of you confronted as you
went through this class,
which is there are very few facts out
there.
Lots of estimates. I mean, even things
like, you know, cash and marketable
securities you start to question after a
while saying, is that really what, you
know, So, Berkshire Hathaway, the cash
is broken up into cash and short-term
investments.
And the accounting numbers we used three
different sources, many of you realized
that the numbers don't always match.
Okay.
Which means you got to make best your
best estimates, your best judgments.
I don't have to tell you this, but we
discovered that the real world is a
messy place.
Things keep changing. Many of your
companies saw their entire business
model start to stagger while you were
doing this morning. I heard there might
be a 100% tariff on movies made outside
the US. If you're doing Netflix,
where every movie seems to be made
outside the US pretty much, you know,
it's in Spanish or Polish and translated
English, that could very well challenge
your best.
When you look at money-making firms, I
told you to pick money-making firms,
some of you during the middle of the
semester discovered your money-making
firm had become a money-losing firm.
Now, I remember in the last week I got
an email from somebody saying, "My
money-making firm has become a
money-losing firm. What should I do?"
You must think I like torturing you.
What am I going to ask you to do? Pick a
different company now? It is it's out of
your control. So, things that happen out
of your control. Now,
markets have gone up and down. I looked
at April, for instance, started ended
the month pretty much where it started.
I called it the most eventful uneventful
month
in my looking at markets, where if you
look at the end start at the end of the
month, let's say you left for the entire
month, you'd come back and just look at
the end, say, "Nothing happened last
month." Which would have been the
furthest thing from the truth.
And, you know, Gleason in developed
markets, we used to think you could look
at companies without worrying having to
worry about politics and government.
Those days are done.
Now, this used to be an emerging market
issue, but now everybody has to think
about the effects.
And finally, I know you felt the urge to
blame me when you got a strange number
out of your spreadsheet.
And I'll take the blame.
But when you put numbers into a capital
structure spreadsheet and get a 0% or
90%, it's coming from your numbers. It's
just a dumb spreadsheet.
You go to the FCFF Ginzu model, you
enter a growth or margin, you get a
strange-looking value, and I got quite a
few emails yesterday saying, "What's
wrong with your model?"
And I said, "Maybe you're a little
tired. Maybe you want to step back and
think about what's driving the model."
Cuz ultimately it's coming from the
inputs. But it's tough to do because you
want to kind of pass the responsibility
on to tools and models, but the reality
is they're your tools.
And this is going to be true even in the
age of AI and and when that comes. So,
let's go back Oh, before I go
do the review of the class, I also took
a look at the companies you picked to
analyze, and there were quite a few
companies that multiple people did. I
think the most analyzed company this
semester
was Palantir.
It doesn't surprise me. It's in the
news, people are fascinated by it.
Netflix, Chipotle, Pepsi, and Starbucks.
I guess I can guess where you get your
food and what you drink. There were four
people each valuing each of those
companies, and EA, Shake Shack, General
Mills, Lululemon, and Marriott had at
least three people analyzing the
company. I'm off often asked, you know,
"So, when you pick a company and you
look and see somebody else has picked
the company." I was asked, "Is it okay
if I pick this company?" And my answer
is always yes, and here's why.
I took Pepsi, which was analyzed by four
people, and these were the numbers that
the four groups put in as summary
numbers. As I present these numbers, you
know those disclaimer statements that
come below every investment banking
email, these are your numbers. So, if
something looks strange in the numbers,
it's not my fault.
I'm just taking the numbers. So, these
are four four analyses of Pepsi, and a
little twist, one of them is a PepsiCo
and the other three is just Pepsi, but I
I guess it's the same company.
On on the power, pretty close to
agreement on institutional all all four.
The betas are regression betas, and
they're all low. So, depending on, you
know, what slice you looked at, I can
see that the betas could be different.
The Jensen's alpha, there's one outlier.
I've no idea yet what that outlier is.
Maybe you used a longer time period, or
maybe you just looked at the wrong
number in the Bloomberg regression page.
Now, you're tired, and I can't blame you
for everything that happens.
The R squared, I should convert it
everything into percentage. I have a
feeling that this third group did do a
regression over a different time period,
because I didn't constrain you, 2 years
versus 5 years, because the R squareds
look different, the the the the overall,
you know, the betas look different. And
if you go all the way across, you can
see on the equity risk premium, there
were three 4.33%.
Which is
I think pretty close to the US equity
risk premium. I haven't again looked at
the numbers closely, but Pepsi does have
some external exposure. You still have
chance to fix it in your report if you
want to, but I wouldn't go and mess with
it, right?
So, the cost of equity vary obviously.
The debt-to-cap ratios, I mean,
basically my point is you can pick the
same company, and none of
In my In my history teaching this class,
no two people looking at a company have
ever come back with the same numbers for
the company. And sometimes you get
dramatically different numbers.
Sometimes it's because of a mistake.
Sometimes it's because you took a
different perspective. So, this notion
that we all agree when we look at the
past data is not is foreign to me,
because you can look at the past data
and draw very different conclusions
based on the slice of data you look at.
So, let's go back to the start of the
class. We talked about the stakeholders
in the company.
The stakeholders, and I broadly broke
them out. You have the shareholders in
the company who effectively own the
company,
but managers don't think the
shareholders own the company, so they
managers seem to think it's their
company. You got lenders who have a very
different interest from shareholders,
and this is going to run all the way
through the class.
Okay. What's the core difference?
Shareholders get a residual claim. They
get upside. Lenders get a contractual
claim, and already you can see the two
interests start to diverge. If you're a
lender, you want me to make very
different choices than a shareholder
does. You got financial markets.
And that relationship we have with
firms, and it's a very tenuous one,
because firms reveal information to
markets, sometimes honestly, sometimes
not, sometimes on time, sometimes not.
Markets try to make their best
assessments
based on that information. And finally,
you got firms in society. And we can
dance the dance and talk about ESG and
sustainability, but the truth is if
these are truly social costs,
you can never put a number on them. And
if you can never put a number on them,
you can dance around them as much as you
want,
but there's no way they're going to get
incorporated into decisions unless you
have laws and regulations.
Voluntary
choices here are not going to deliver
the results.
And we talked about the conflicts of
interest at play.
Shareholders, we said, often have little
power over managers. So, what do they
do? They put their interests over
managerial interests.
Lenders lend money to a firm. If they
don't protect themselves, they will get
ripped off.
Right?
Remember the Nabisco being Nabisco. Keep
that in your lexicon whenever you see a
company or a person lending. Managers
sometimes delay news cuz sometimes
outright lie. And markets are not
angelic, either. They often make choices
that don't look rational. The prices are
And finally, there are significant
social costs and sometimes social
benefits that companies create or
businesses create in the process of
running businesses.
So, one of the first things I asked you
is how much power do you see in your
company
shareholders having over managers? And I
put in a zero to two. I mean, I could
have put zero to 10, but basically I
wanted to keep the choices limited
because you can't really finesse it.
Two being complete power, zero being no
power. So, based on what you entered in,
there were the about about 10% of the
companies. There were 229 companies,
about 23 of them you said shareholders
have no power.
My guess is many of these are family
group companies, the companies with two
class of voting rights who say, "Look, I
as a shareholder, I'm just going to buy
the shares and hope for the best."
About 36% of companies, you chose 0.5,
which means some power but not very
much. You know, I don't know why there's
a second end of the significant. 32%
you put in 1.5. Basically, you're moving
towards more power. And there were 19%
companies where you effectively felt
shareholders ran the company. So,
already you can see even with the mix of
class companies you have, you're in the
typical company shareholders don't have
as much power as we assume in
traditional Why does this matter?
Because every decision you make you you
see a company make after this point,
when you look at why did they borrow
what they did? Why did they pay the
dividends? They really go back to this
core issue, which is who are managers
accountable to? And if they don't feel
accountable to shareholders, they're
going to make choices that don't seem to
make sense.
Then I asked you, "Who's your marginal
investor?" And this pie I might as well
have dispensed with the pie.
Almost every company,
the marginal investor is institutional.
Even smaller companies.
And the reason is very simple.
It's not even that they need to own a
lot of shares, but the bulk of the
trading comes from institutions. They're
the ones Why does this matter?
Why does it matter who the marginal
investor is? Why why do we make such a
big issue of it?
But fill in the blanks. Marginal
investor is institutional. What is it
about institutional investors we assume
that allows you to use a beta?
That's not sufficient. There's something
else marginal investors need to do. Yes?
They're diversified. This is what all of
finance is built on, right? That
marginal investors, if they're
diversified, the risk they see in
investment is It's central to finance,
as we know.
Modern finance was born when Harry
Markowitz walked into that library in
Princeton in the 1950s as a PhD student.
Cuz at that time, the belief was the
risk of a company comes from what it
does.
And he started thinking about, "What if
I have five companies, 10 companies?"
And modern finance was born because he
said, "If you are a diversified
investor, the way you think about risk
changes dramatically than if you're not
a diversified investor."
Now, why are so many of your companies
driven by institutional investors?
Because partly by by the choices you
made, right? You did not pick
low-profile companies, really small
companies,
very small emerging market companies,
even in the US very small lightly traded
companies where, in fact, the marginal
investor could be
the owner or somebody who's
undiversified. And if that had happened,
then what would we have needed to do?
We needed cost of equity and cost of
capital. You'd have had to move towards
a total beta.
Liam, your music business is privately
owned business, right? So, if Liam had
picked You didn't You didn't pick your
business to do, but if you'd have done
your business in the in this section,
you'd have said the marginal investor is
probably not diversified.
So, I'm therefore going to when I think
about cost of equity, at least think
about the rest of the risk because I
don't have the luxury of saying all of
the other risk is going to dissipate.
So, that's why we care about who the
marginal investor is. It's not so much
that institutional investors are going
to come in and aggressively make you
change your policy. They don't.
But the fact that they're the ones
driving prices means I can focus on
betas.
So, the marginal investor discussion
leads you into beta. And the three key
inputs that drive your cost of equity
are your risk-free rate,
your beta, and already we
Remember beta measures the risk you
cannot diversify away. And if you look
at, you know, what you're going to see
in terms of the R-squared, much of the
risk in most of your companies is
company-specific, and we're actually
deliberately ignoring it because
investors are diversified.
And an equity risk premium.
For most of you, your risk-free rate
was the UST bond rate.
Remind me, friends, why did you use the
US T-bond Why was so many people using
the US T-bond rate as the risk-free
rate?
Incorporated is not enough. Remember You
chose to analyze the companies in US
dollars, right? You can be incorporated
in the US. I could do it in euros or
pesos. We chose to do the analysis in
dollars.
And why do we use the T-bond rate as the
risk-free rate? Like Henry?
What were you implicitly assuming about
the US Treasury?
No default risk, right?
That's getting to become a little shaky
in the last few weeks. In fact, in my
post that I wrote on Saturday I don't
know what possessed me to actually write
that on Saturday. I had so many things
to do, but I just wrote it. I looked at
the US sovereign CDS spread. Remember we
talked about sovereign CDS spreads?
Sovereign The US sovereign CDS spread
started April of 2025
at about 48 basis points, 0.48%.
By the end of the month, it was at
0.65%. Still not You We're not Argentina
yet, but that's not saying much, right?
There is at least this fear that's
creeping in that the US might not be as
trustworthy as people used to think 10,
20, 30,
or even, you know, 50 years ago.
What does that mean? Is it possible that
next semester I teach this class, which
won't be till spring of 2027,
that the US dollar risk-free rate might
get a little messier?
You know, what do I What might I have to
do?
Start with the T-bond rate.
What do we do with Indian rupee?
We netted out a default spread. It's not
the end of the world from a from an from
a practical perspective, but it kind of
shakes
the US dollar being the global currency
of choice for the last century. So,
essentially, that might happen. I am
ready for it when it happens. I'm not
going to freak out.
But there will be people who freak out
because now you got to factor in that
So, the risk-free rate is in the
currency of your choice.
We talked about betas, and then we
talked about equity risk premiums.
When you think about equity risk
premiums, yes, go ahead, Callum.
No, no, wait. You can't go across
currencies, right? To get the won
risk-free rate, what did you do?
So, you used a government bond rate in
won? You can't go to the dollar
risk-free rate if you're doing analysis
in won, right?
I don't want you to make you make you do
your entire project all over again, but
I'm curious. But To get a won risk-free
rate, there are two ways you can do it.
You can take the won government bond
rate and subtract out the default spread
in Korean won, which is not big. It's
like, you know, South Korea is pretty
highly rated. But you'd still be
subtracting out 0.5, 0.6% to get to
risk-free rate. The other is to take the
UST bond rate and take the differential
inflation between South
Did you go the second route or the
You'd have to pick a different risk-free
rate or do the dollar risk-free rate
clean it up. So, whatever you start as
your risk-free rate has to be truly
risk-free.
So, it will it will mean more work
because it'd be nice to have used the
T-bond rate as a risk-free rate, but you
can't hold on to something just because
it was nice to do.
The equity risk premium, there are two
ways we estimate it, right? One is we
look backwards.
Actually, let me take the we. A lot of
people do. I've stopped doing it since
2008. I think we have to be
forward-looking.
What does that mean? It's dynamic. How
dynamic? During April, I computed it
every single day. Sounds like a lot of
work, but it's really but 2 minutes at
the end of the day I went in and said,
"What's the equity risk premium today?"
I didn't do it for others. I did it for
me because I needed to get my head on
straight because you were essentially
losing your head as you looked at what
markets were doing and what people were
saying.
A forward-looking or a backward-looking
and it's got to reflect where you
operate.
Right? To me, that seems like common
sense. If your business is in Nigeria,
I'd be demanding a much higher equity
risk premium than if if you're in
Germany. So, it's got to factor in both
being forward-looking and where you
operate.
So, on beta, I made a big deal about the
way we've all taught betas, including
me, which is run a regression, right?
Run a regression, take the slope of the
line
and get the beta.
I promise you when you get out this
summer,
I mean most of you many of you might be
interning at investment banks,
almost everybody will be using a
Bloomberg beta,
which is a regression beta.
I'm going to check to see whether you
got the ammunition
to tell them why it's a bad idea. So,
Kelly, tell me the three reasons why a
regression beta
is not a good beta. She can get started
and then you can go to the other two.
It's backward-looking, right?
And why do we care? Because we need a
beta for the next 5 years, not beta for
the last 5 years. So, that was the easy
one. So, I'm not going to pick on Kelly
again. Somebody tell me a second reason.
Jacob, what's the second reason why?
It's standard error. It's noisy. I like
the word noisy because it kind of
conveys it's not that regression betas
are bad. They don't give you a number.
There's a range on the beta, right? The
standard error.
They're backward-looking. They're noisy.
And if your business or company changes
its business mix or leverage over the 5
years, and what company doesn't,
your regression beta, even if it's
precise, becomes useless.
So, I offered you an alternative. In
fact, I I thrust this alternative down
your throat saying, "This is the
alternative."
And the alternative is rather than look
at a regression beta, you build up to a
beta by looking at what business or
businesses
your company operates in.
Remember the Disney five business
example?
Try updating it to 2025, right? The
businesses will change, but essentially
we'll build up the businesses by first
identifying the businesses, then looking
up the unlevered beta of being in that
business. Now, how the heck do you get
that? You look at publicly traded
companies in that space. You clean up
for the debt and the cash.
It's called a pure play beta and you
take a weighted average, preferably
based on value.
Why preferably? Because often you don't
get value, right? Because the businesses
are not traded, you get revenues or
operating income. And I said, "No, try
to convert into value
and take those weighted take that
weighted average."
Why is that weighted average better?
First, because you're averaging out
across 50 or 100 companies, that number
is going to be more precise. The noise
problem goes away.
Second, it is backward-looking in one
sense, but it's forward-looking now
because you base it on the business or
businesses you expect your company to
operate
It's less noisy. It's more
forward-looking.
And I tried to push you towards it.
I don't have the results yet for you,
but I'll update this for the next time I
teach.
But in spring of 2023,
I looked at the betas that people used
in the project. I did I don't know that
yet, right? Because I I didn't ask you
which one did you use to get your cost
of equity and cost of capital in your
project.
And I want this pie to be just one
choice, but it never gets there.
So, 91% of people that semester used
bottom-up betas. I hope that's 93%
but I'm realistic it won't be 100%.
There will be people who stuck with
their regression beta. They happen to be
one of them. I'm not going to take issue
with you, but I'm going to look for your
reason, right? And there are three
reasons you could give me. One is, "My
company is so unique that I cannot find
companies like it."
It's in a new business.
You say there are no new businesses.
There are new ways of delivering old
businesses.
Was there car service before Uber? Yes.
Was Uber the first ride-sharing company?
Absolutely.
Was there advertising before Google and
Facebook? Yes.
Did Google and Facebook create online
Yes. So, basically, you can have a
business and a company that has a unique
way of delivering that business.
The The music business was not just
upended but devastated
by Apple creating iTunes. It kind of
upended the entire business model. And
then of course,
you know, Napster initially tried to rip
off music. It got pushed out, but Apple
replaced and finally Spotify stepped
into the fray. Is Spotify the first
business to make money off music?
Absolutely not.
So, when you think about unique
companies,
doesn't mean that they're unique
businesses. So, if that was your You
don't Again, don't use any of this
stuff. I have to go back and rewrite the
project. That's not the end game. I'm
not going to pick on you for doing it,
but if that was the reason, try to
rethink what that is. The second is and
this
I usually get a couple of people doing
this is
"Now, my company is in only one
business. Therefore, a bottom-up beta
will not work for me."
No, because it it's almost as if you see
that the weighting is where the benefits
of bottom-up betas come from, but that's
not where it comes from, right? If even
if you're a steel company and you're
only in the steel business, that
that law of large numbers working in
your favor is still going to work out.
You should still be using a bottom-up
beta.
And the third one I know many of you
wrestle with.
You had a regression beta which gave you
one number.
You got a bottom-up beta that was a very
different number.
That troubled you.
And you said, "They're very different.
What should I do?" Let me ask you a
question. If bottom-up betas and
regression betas usually give you
numbers that are pretty close to each
other,
why would we go through this
torture of estimating bottom-up betas?
It's precisely because it will give you
different numbers.
And I'm putting my weight or bet on the
bottom-up beta when it's different
rather So, in fact, it's precisely for
companies we get different numbers that
the bottom-up beta is so useful.
Now, I looked up your the betas. I asked
you for your regression betas. This is
what the distribution of betas across
your companies looks like. Right?
By itself, you're saying, "What's the
big deal?" The median beta across your
companies is 1.14. Rishika, what's your
What should the These were randomly
picked. What should the median beta be?
What What What do the betas average out
to?
They should average out to one, right?
So, I want you to keep tabs on what your
typical company is going to look like,
but it's not because it's not a median
company. So, it's riskier than average.
File that away. Right?
I looked at your Jensen's alpha.
Remember this is
The Jensen's alpha measures how well or
badly your stock did during the period
of the regression after adjusting for
the market and after adjusting for risk.
So, the average Jensen's alpha across
all stocks should be zero, right? Your
median Jensen's alpha was 0.24% and 52%
of companies earned positive Jensen's
alphas. So, your typical company was
higher risk than average,
had more positive returns than the
typical company.
And the R-squared that you got
was the median R-squared was about 11%.
Remember we talked about the risk we
ignore? In your median company, we're
ignoring 89% of the risk on the
rationale that investors can diversify
it. Well, now you can already see why
this makes people uncomfortable,
especially managers because I see all
that risk. You're telling me to ignore
it.
Your median company in this class
tended to be riskier than average,
have positive Jensen's alphas, and have
a lower R-squared than the typical
company.
And I take some of the blame or
responsibility for that because what
were you required to do when you picked
a company?
Restrict yourself to
money-making companies.
Right?
And I also said avoid banks and
financial service companies. In a sense,
I'm skewing your choices and it starts
to show up in the numbers you see there.
So, it doesn't mean you went out and
deliberately tried to skew it. It's a
nature of your I mean, we create bias in
samples in the most subtle ways and I
created my own bias in the sample of
companies you ended up analyzing.
So, any questions about beta, risk-free
rate, risk premium, and cost of equity?
The cost of equity, of course, becomes
an input
your cost of capital.
Cost of equity is what equity investors
in a company demand
as a hurdle rate, right?
Cost of capital brings in the fact that
you can borrow money and that borrowed
money has a cost and the cost is very
simple. It's a risk-free rate plus the
default spread you face as a company.
And if you're in a country with default
risk, that might add to the risk as
well.
And there's one bonus you get when you
borrow money, which is interest is tax
deductible. So, you bring in the tax
benefits of debt into your after-tax
cost of debt.
To get the default spread, if you had an
actual rating and many of you had actual
ratings, I said just look up the spread.
Don't go looking for trouble. And the
reason I underplay this calculation
is in a minute I'm going to show you
what the debt ratios for your companies
look like.
And for most of your companies it was
10, 15, 20%. Jacob's doing MGM, his debt
ratio is 74%. For him, the cost of debt
is a big deal.
Right? Because if you get it off, your
cost of capital is going to be off.
But for many of you, your debt ratio is
3, 5, 10, 15%.
I mean, in corporate finance and
business in general, you got to decide
where to put your attention because
finessing the cost of debt is not going
to do much for you.
But basically, you're looking at the
defaulters coming through the default
spread
and applying the The reason most of you
can get up get get away applying the one
minus the marginal tax rate is because I
forced you to pick money-making
companies.
If you have a money-losing company,
that's going to be messy, right? Because
interest is tax deductible, but to get
that tax deduction, you got to make
money.
So, if you're a money company that has
never made money and doesn't plan to
make money in the next 5 years, you
might not want to put the one minus T in
there because there is going to be no
tax benefit.
And when we think about the weights, I
said, at least in corporate finance,
when you do debt ratios and cost of
capital, the weights have to be market
value weights.
So, here's what your actual debt to
capital ratios look like. And this is
why I said Jacob's company is the
exception because you can see that the
companies you picked, in addition to
being higher risk
and positive Jensen's alpha, tend to be
lightly levered.
The median debt ratio across your
companies was 15%. The third quartile
was 27%.
Are there companies with very high debt
ratios? Yeah, about two, three, four
companies. Many of them
are companies which are infrastructure
companies.
Why do casino companies borrow? They I'm
sure MGM is not the only casino company
with a lot of debt. Why do you think
casino companies borrow a lot of money?
Them in particular, pretty unique
because they spun off all of these
debts. You know, they had spun off all
their real estate assets into a REIT and
then sold it and then leased all
properties. So, it also had a lot of
debt. Well, in a sense, it it's almost
slight of hand, right? Because you
you create a separate entity and you
lease it back from it. It's still debt.
You know what? This made sense in the
old days when you could sneak under the
debt definition by taking it off the
books, but it doesn't work for them
anymore, right? But in general, casino
companies do tend to have a lot of debt.
Wynn Resorts,
Sands,
Las Vegas Sands.
There are two things that drive it. One
is
Have you driven by a typical a casino in
in Vegas?
It's an extremely tasteful affair,
usually.
Uh it's I'm being sarcastic. But it's an
incredibly expensive, tasteless
building, right? How they managed to
combine the two in one investment, I
don't know. Spend hundreds of millions
of dollars create something that people
look at and say, "Really?"
The first thing it cost them a lot of
money. So, there
And And I'll tell you where I'm leading
up to. Their argument is we need to
borrow money because our investments are
so expensive.
Do they need to borrow money? Is there
another choice they could have made?
They could have raised equity, right?
So, the question is why don't companies,
especially the Wynn Resorts and and the
Sands Las Vegas Sands, raise equity?
What is raising equity mean? You have to
issue shares
and raise equity. When you issue shares,
the Adelsons own 52% of the shares
in Sands in Las Vegas Sands. You issue
shares, what's going to happen? Your
ownership stake drops below I mean, I I
say this in my valuation class, but
casino companies tend to be run by
megalomaniacs.
If you don't believe me, look at who's
on top. You need a special mindset to
say, "I'm going to build, you know, a
replica of the Taj Mahal right in Las
Vegas, right?"
And when you're a megalomaniac, you
don't like to give up control.
So, often companies say, "I I have no
choice. I have to have a high debt
ratio." I said, "That's not true. You've
chosen to have a high debt ratio because
you don't want to give up control."
But you can see the typical company. And
I'll be quite honest, when I hear people
on CNBC saying US companies are
hopelessly over-levered,
you can you're entitled to your
opinions, but not to your facts. The
typical US company has less debt now
than 10 years ago or 20 years ago. You
can have other issues the way US
companies are run, but debt is not high
up on the list of sins when you look at
what what they do.
So, that's your debt ratio that goes
into your cost of capital and you can
see the variation in cost of capital.
Nobody picked a really high inflation
currency to work with and I don't blame
you.
I don't think there were any Venezuelan
bolivar cost of capital, Argentine pesos
because it's just messy when you get to
double-digit risk rates. Now, I was
hoping that somebody would pick a
Turkish company to analyze.
Okay? In Turkish lira,
because the risk free rate is 21, 22%
because you're going to see the numbers
start and you can see very quickly why
running a business when inflation is
that high becomes incredibly difficult
to do.
So, you got a cost of capital and this
was what, week six, week seven of the
class. And then I said, "Let's take a
look at the quality of existing
investments." And I gave you two
metrics, both flawed, to get a measure
of how good or bad your investments are.
And they were both based on accounting
numbers.
One was to take the net income that the
company has and divide it by the book
value of equity to get a return on
equity.
The other is to take the operating
income after taxes and divide it not
just by the book value of equity, but
the book value of equity plus debt minus
cash, invested capital, to get a return
on capital.
As I said, these have become magical
numbers to consultants.
You got to be skeptical about them
because they're accounting numbers and
many of you saw the results of
accounting choices on these numbers.
There were at least 25 companies with
the book value of equity was negative.
So, if you had a company with a negative
book value of equity, you were not
alone.
How do they become negative? One is to
lose a lot of money over a long period,
but many of these companies didn't get
there
by losing money. They got there by
buying back stock or paying dividends
and the act of buying back stock alone
now pushes your book equity negative
because often market equity is five
times book equity. If Apple bought back
15% of its stock, maybe 10% of its
stock, its book equity would turn
negative.
Will it affect the market cap? Not in
the least because nobody cares about
book equity other than accountants.
Financial service firms, maybe, but for
the rest of the Who cares what's in the
on the books?
But if you compare that return on
capital to the cost of capital, return
on equity to cost of equity, you're
getting a measure of quality. And you're
saying, "What if the two give you
different answers?" Some of you, I think
MGM again, had return on equity that
exceeded its cost of equity, but its
return on capital
was less than the cost of capital.
When the two give you a different
signals, which one is more reliable?
I would go with the return on capital
and cost of capital.
Return on equity because your your
equity sliver is so small, all you need
is a swing in your net income and say,
"Hey, I've got great projects." It's for
precisely that reason when real estate
people talk about return on equity, I
would like to see return on capital as
well because you're looking at 10% of
the building and you're telling me I'm
getting a great return on equity, but
that could very quickly change next
year.
But they're both trying, and the keyword
is trying to get a sense Are Are your
existing projects good projects or bad
projects? If you remember that table I
showed you, 70% of global companies have
trouble earning their cost of capital.
But in your case, your median company
earned a return on capital that was
5.56% higher than the cost of capital.
Already you can stick you see the stack
of characteristics building your
company. It's higher risk than the
typical company, has a positive Jensen's
alpha,
and actually earns more than the cost of
capital. You're looking at companies
that are already exceptional in a global
sense because you're looking at the 30%.
Now, there are two measures we have of
company quality, right? Jensen's alpha
and this excess return.
The Jensen's alpha, if it's positive,
means your stock did better than
expected.
The excess return, if it's positive,
means you're taking projects that earn
more than your cost of capital.
And they two can sometimes diverge. You
can have a company with a positive
Jensen's alpha and a negative excess
return.
They earn less than the cost of capital.
Or you can have a company with a
negative Jensen's alpha
and a positive excess return. And that
sometimes puzzles people. How can I be
picking a company that earns more than
its cost of capital market seems to be
punishing it.
Anybody want to resolve that
contradiction? Why might a company earn
more than its cost of capital and still
see its stock price go down?
Let me give you an analogy most of you
are not close to, but maybe 10 years
from now. Let's say you have three kids
and you stop at three. Why? Do you like
an odd number, right?
Let's say one kid is an A quality kid,
gets A's every time. The other is a B
quality kid, gets B's every time. And
the third is a C quality kid, takes life
easy and the same.
And they all come back one semester with
B's.
So, the A quality kid who comes back
with a B, you're
disappointed, right? You're a good
parent. You You're just disappointed.
The B quality kid who comes back with a
B, you're saying, "That's what I
expected." The C quality K 2 comes back
with a B. This is like the prodigal son.
Right?
Do you see how this plays out in
markets?
You have a company that makes 10% more
than its cost of capital consistently.
You have another company that makes its
cost of capital consistently. And you
have a company that makes 10% less than
its cost of capital consistently. It's a
terrible company and continues to be
terrible.
And once one one earnings report, all
three come in
making their cost of capital.
The company that you expected to make
10% more than expected delivered far
less. You're going to knock its stock
price down.
The company that you expected to just
break even came in exactly as expected.
Nothing will happen. But the company
that you expected to make 10% If GM ever
matched its cost of capital, it'd be
time for dancing in the streets.
That hasn't happened in 20 years.
Even airline delivers 8% more than the
cost of capital, I'm putting it on a
pedestal. You're a software company, you
earned only 5% more than your cost of
capital, I'm disappointed. The game of
expectations is what drives markets.
And it's a very dangerous game because
the better you do, the higher the
expectations get. And the higher the
expectations get, the more difficult it
becomes match. And take a look at
Nvidia's last three earnings reports.
It's matched or beaten analyst
expectations and its stock price goes
down every single time. Why? Cuz
markets' expectations have been, "Hey,
this company can beat." It's a very
strange game that you can beat analyst
expectations by 8%. You beat it by only
2%, that's a disappointment.
Jensen's alpha's driven by expectations,
your excess returns delivered. You know,
I have a piece on why great companies
might not be great investments and you
can see why, right? You're going to a
great company and everybody expects you
to be great.
See the upside?
You're really good, that's not good
enough.
You're an awful company, everybody
expects you to stay awful,
you might be a great investment because
all you have to do is be less than awful
and that's a positive surprise.
Then I asked you to compute the optimal
debt ratio.
And I gave you a tool, right? That
because I don't want didn't want you to,
you know, grind through computing debt
ratios 10, 20.
But if you had to do it,
you should be able to do it. It's not
rocket science, it's just a little bit
of it's messy, you got to do those
iterations.
But the spreadsheet does it, comes up
with an optimal debt ratio. And across
your companies, your median optimal debt
ratio. So now we're talking about the
the optimal debt ratio, not the actual,
was about 30% and about 50% of companies
fell between 10 and 40.
But there were companies out there
which had optimal debt ratios of 75, 80,
90%.
Now, before without even looking at the
numbers, what is it that drives your
optimal
uh
debt ratio? What is it that gave gives
some of your companies Cuz some of you
ended up with really low optimals and
you probably said, "This is a really
good company. How come my optimal debt
ratio is so low?" And others ended up
with really high optimals and you said,
"But this company wasn't that good, but
how come it can borrow 80% or 90%?" What
are the drivers of the optimal debt
ratio?
Exam's only 1 week from now, right?
What's a key driver first? What's a
reason we borrow money?
Taxes. So first could be tax, right? But
that probably was not the reason unless
you're a company in your group that had
a zero or a very low tax rate. So maybe
you were doing Ryanair as part of
airlines and you could end up with a low
optimal. So one is tax rate.
But my guess is that wasn't a big
you know, differentiating variable for
most of you Many of you were doing just
US companies and just European companies
without without Ireland.
What's the other factor that gives
companies different optimals?
Yes. Bankruptcy costs.
Bankruptcy costs could play a role, but
I don't see it entering that directly
into why you end up with an 80% or a 10%
optimal in But you're right, what is it
that drives bankruptcy in this model? Is
when your
interest expense keeps rising relative
to your operating income, right? That's
where you get into debt bankruptcy
trouble.
You know what drives interest expenses
how much you borrow. This is leading
somewhere,
if you're a company that's very highly
priced. Take a Palantir.
Right? You take 10% of their value.
Doesn't sound like much, right? 10%, but
10% of Palantir's value or 10% of
Nvidia's value is going to be a huge
amount of debt.
In Nvidia, that's going to be 300
billion in debt.
You take the interest expense on 300
billion, you're going to have a tough
time even if you're a money-making
company meeting those interest expenses.
What drives differences in optimal is
what you have as cash flows relative to
your market value. That's why really
good companies will end up with low
optimal debt ratios because the
expectations again will drive up the
market cap.
The kinds of companies that end up with
really high optimal debt ratios are
companies where the market has turned
against the company.
But its numbers are still holding up, at
least for the moment.
So if your market value collapses, your
earnings stay high and you put those
numbers in, you're going to end up with
really high optimal debt ratios. Or
you're a company with volatile earnings.
Remember I, you know, you used last
year's operating income. I know the you
know, whoever was doing
Who was Who was doing Delta Airlines and
getting a really high optimal?
Yes, somebody was doing Delta Airlines
and getting a high optimal.
But the reason is 2024 was a really good
year for Delta Airlines. The EBIT
reflected that. But the market value
reflected the more realistic assumption
markets were making, this is a good
year, but this too shall pass.
And there will be bad years. I've got to
price it based on that. So you can
either have cyclical companies where you
can end up with a high optimal or you
can end up with companies where the
business model is broken, there's been
disruption. It's not showing up in the
numbers yet.
Now, that might be something to factor
in as tariffs become a real threat. Is
some companies you're going to see the
market prices drop because of that
expectation of damage from tariffs?
But the earnings are still going to be
2024 earnings. So these companies are
going to look good both on a pricing
basis and in the capacity to borrow
money.
But you shouldn't be pushing them to go
to borrow that money because they really
can't afford that.
I also asked you, is your company under
or over levered? Your median company
is So that negative number means its
actual debt ratio is lower than the
optimal.
Doesn't surprise me. This is always been
true every semester I teach the class.
More companies emerge as under levered
than over levered, and thank God for
that.
If most companies are over levered, you
got a problem at the at the market
level.
Korea for instance in the 1990s, you did
every company, every company came in as
over levered based on their operating
income.
Cuz the government acted as this
implicit guarantor, the governments took
advantage of it. The whole thing blew up
in '96, almost took the Korean economy
down with it.
If you're going to make a mistake, it's
better to be under levered than over
levered. About 69 companies out of you
There were 225 companies, 69 came out as
over levered.
Your task trying to get them back to
their right leverage is much more
arduous
than the 156 that ended up with under
levered companies. So more likely to be
under levered than over levered.
In fact, when we're done, you should
make a list of the characteristics of a
typical company picked in this class and
you're going to see
there's a pattern that emerges.
I did ask you what the right kind of
financing for your company is. And I
asked you to steer away from trusting
that macro regression too much. Why?
It's a small sample, you can get
strange-looking numbers. It's, you know,
do it based on intuition.
Intuition basically means if you have
long-term projects, you should be using
long-term debt. You tell me where you do
business and your currency mix should
reflect it. If you have pricing power,
you should be more likely to use
floating rate debt. And if you have any
special features in your company, you
can build it to the debt. That would be
nice. You know, in all companies, it'd
be nice to link your coupon rates. You
know, it's not rocket science, it's
matching your debt up to your assets
because by doing that, you reduce your
default risk.
Now, many of you probably saw in your
companies mismatches if you had debt.
Does MGM have the right kind of debt? I
think leases are the right kind of debt.
You know why?
Cuz if things go really badly, you just
walk away from that specific lease.
BlackRock is doing this in a bunch of
malls
where they think that their mall cannot
stand alone. They're investors in malls.
You know, they they've let and they
basically said, "Look,
this mall is too bad, you can take it as
a bank." This is not good for a bank.
And this is why I don't think banks
should ever lend based on
the liquidation value of an asset. It's
a terrible way to do banking. If the
only way you can collect your money back
is by selling the underlying asset,
you've already lost the script there.
Right?
So leases do make sense for MGM. But for
some of your companies, you could see a
mismatch and if you can fix that
mismatch, you reduce the cost.
Then we got to dividends and I said, you
got to figure out how much your company
can afford to pay in dividends. Said
it's all in that statement of cash
flows, right?
So you start with net income and then
you add back depreciation and
amortization of other non-cash charges.
Then you subtract the change in working
capital. In the statement of cash flows,
you've got what they call operating cash
flow, but it's really operating cash
flows to equity investors.
And then you subtract out capex,
acquisitions, other investments.
That gives you free cash flow to equity
before debt payments, and then you bring
in what did I borrow, how much do I
repay, you end up with free cash flow to
equity. Don't let the acronym become
something you hide behind. Right?
Because when when you tell somebody free
cash flow to equity, I mean it's it's
not something that people are familiar
with. Free cash flow to equity is cash
left in the till after you met every
conceivable need. It's what companies
can afford to pay out. Doesn't mean that
they will.
It's what they can afford to pay out.
So, I did ask you what your company paid
out in dividends and buybacks. Re- you
know, first I asked you what you know,
dividend versus buybacks. And across
your companies,
if you look at the person of comp- the
median dividend as a percentage, I'm
sorry, that should be the wrong title.
The median dividend
Uh median by I'm sorry, the buybacks as
a percentage dividends was about 60% for
the typical company in this class, 60%
of the cash got returned in the form of
buybacks. That shouldn't be surprising
because that's what the entire market
looks like. Would it be different if you
picked a lot of emerging market and
European companies? It'd probably be
lower. But because most of you picked US
companies, a big chunk of the cash was
returned in the form of buybacks. In
fact, in at least a third of your
companies, the only way the company
returned cash
was buybacks. I've been tracking this
now for almost 20 years, and this
statistic has steadily risen over time.
And I wouldn't be surprised if 20 years
from now
dividend paying companies were unusual
or exceptional.
I mean, I think in in many ways I've
said dividends don't make sense as a way
of returning residual cash flows.
Because you commit yourself to paying it
year after year.
Di- you know, buybacks to me are
flexible dividends. Doesn't mean they
always make sense.
Sometimes companies buyback stock that
they shouldn't, but the bulk of your
cash was returned in the form of
buybacks.
I did compare how much cash your
companies returned
as a person of free cash flow to equity.
Notice the reason I don't care about
your currencies other than the fact that
I have begged you not to put in your
currency and physically in with the
number
is it makes my life difficult because
I've got to go remove that because no
arithmetic operation works on it
anymore.
Is I look at ratios.
So, I look at cash returned as a person
of free cash flow to equity. So, what do
we expect to see? That free cash flow to
equity should be returned as dividends,
but we also said most companies choose
not to.
In fact, in your typical company, the
median cash returned was about 73%
of free cash equity.
So, Leon, what happens to the other 27%
of these companies? Where does that cash
go? When you don't return a free cash
flow to equity, where does that cash go?
No, can't be reinvestment because free
cash flow is
free cash equity is already ca- after
capex and after change in reinvestment,
after acquisition, so it has to go into
the cash balance.
So, these companies' cash is building
up. Is that a bad thing?
Constantine, what do you think? Is it a
bad thing for com- for a company you've
invested in to build up cash?
Depends, right? Depends on what? Depends
on how much you trust the management of
the company
with your cash.
I'm okay. I'm an Apple shareholder. I'm
okay with Apple accumulating 200 billion
of my cash. Why?
Because Tim Cook doesn't strike me as a
man who'll get drunk on a Saturday night
and buy a big company on a Sunday,
right?
He doesn't strike me as somebody who
does things impulsively.
But there are companies I worry
not because CEOs going to get drunk on a
Saturday night and buy a company on a
Sunday, but they seem like impulsive
people. They seem like overconfident
people.
Overconfidence worries me more than any
other aspect of top management. What
does overconfidence mean? Basically, you
assume you can pull it off because
you're you.
You're special.
You have somebody like that as a CEO, I
want my money back as soon as I can
because I worry about what he can do
with my cash.
And then at the very end of the class,
and I know it came late in the semester,
I asked you to value the company.
I know you just opened up that FCFF
Simple Ginzburg in the last week. You
probably made up a growth rate a month
because you needed to get done. I
completely accept that, right? So, I'm
not going to put in in an immense amount
of weight on what you came up with the
value, but those are the levers that you
need to think about when you value a
company.
Right? You could value company based on
equity, where you're looking at cash
flows to equity and discounting at the
cost of equity, or take cash flows of
firm and discounting at the cost of
capital.
That's a choice you have to make early
on because every input you estimate has
to be based on that choice. If you do
things entirely based on equity, your
cash flows will have to be cash flows
after debt payments, free cash flow
Your growth rate has to be a growth rate
in net income, equity income.
And at some point in time,
you got to put closure on all models.
Why? Because you can't estimate cash
cash flows forever. That's your terminal
value calculation. You discount them all
back at the cost of equity, you valued
equity.
I very rarely value a business based on
But the reasons I talked in Jacob about
MGM, you take equity, you look at the
cash flows, God only knows what I'm
looking at as a slice, right? I want to
look at cash flows before debt payments.
That's my free cash flow to the firm.
The growth rate I want to look at is
growth in operating income, so you're
not playing games in the net income
numbers.
I still have to put closure, but the
discount rate I will use is the cost of
capital. What you get is the value of
the entire business. You still have to
add cash, subtract out debt to get the
value of equity. But those are the two
frameworks we looked at.
So,
you put your numbers in the FC- So,
again, take it with a grain of salt.
Happened in the last week. You were
really exhausted yesterday. You just had
to get the Simple Ginzburg spreadsheet.
With all those caveats,
you found you know, across your
companies, your median company,
so this is basically price divided by
your DCF value. So, the number is grea-
If the numbers are 100%, your company's
fairly valued. If it's more than 100%,
your stock is overvalued. Your median
company is overvalued by about 20%.
120.33.
of your companies
were overvalued, 70 were undervalued.
I know some of you are in my valuation
class. I'm going to show the statistic
as well. I've looked at all three
classes this semester. The breakdown is
about 40% undervalued, 60% overvalued. I
have that statistic going back 25 years,
which I'll show in my valuation class.
If you're interested, you can come and
take a look at it. It's a statistic that
varied across time, but at least at the
moment you're finding more companies
overvalued
than undervalued.
So, start with corporate governance all
the way through value.
And I left you with the question that I
didn't ask you to answer on this project
is can you change the value of your
company? You have the levers now under
your control, right? You can take better
projects if you you know, if you're in a
good business or take fewer projects if
you're in a bad business. You can change
your mix of debt and equity, match your
debt up to lower your cost of capital.
You can build your competitive
advantages to grow longer, but
ultimately everything has to show up in
one or more of those inputs.
Yesterday I was talking to somebody
about sustainability.
And I said, you want if you really want
to make a case for sustainability, show
me where it's going to show up.
Because if it's not going to show up, no
matter how good it sounds,
nothing will happen.
It's got to show up. It doesn't have to
be next year's ca- not short-term or
long-term. If you can show me it'll
happen in the cash flow 7 years from
now, I'm willing to I give you I give
now.
It's not a question of time horizon,
it's a question of show me a pathway in
which something shows up. So, when you
talk about changing the way a company's
run, I'm going to push you for
specifics. What would you change about
this company?
And you have at least the basic
framework for thinking about what should
you change and what should you not. And
if you run into a perfectly managed,
perfectly run company, follow the
Hippocratic oath.
Do no harm.
Don't tell a company to do things simply
because you feel you have to tell them.
It's a It's a classic consulting
problem, right? You walk into a company,
everything's already well run. If you
told them I see nothing you need to
change, they're probably going to say
you're not a very good consultant.
So, what do you do? You make up stuff.
You tell them you should change this,
you should change that, and you leave
them worse off than they were because
you're trying to change things that
should not be changed.
So, I looked across your companies, and
I was looking for a trifecta. And I'll
explain what this trifect- why this
trifecta is significant. I was looking
for companies which earned a return on
capital higher than the cost of capital.
Why? Because you're taking good
projects.
But we said most companies that take
good projects tend to be priced as such,
so I kept going.
Then I looked at your debt ratio, and I
wanted to see whether your company was
underlevered or overlevered.
So, I look for companies that make more
than their cost of capital,
have too little debt.
And then I looked at your dividend
policy to see if you're a company that
was holding back cash. In other words,
you're not paying out.
You have good projects,
you're underlevered, you're holding
you're paying out too little in cash.
And then I made a final stop, I looked
at the evaluation to see if you were
undervalued.
Good projects
under leveraged, paying out less, and
undervalued. You see why?
This is almost the perfect company to
jump in because one or another can
change and give you the payoff.
The under leverage can be fixed, the
cash can be returned, and the company is
undervalued, the valuation, the price
might move to value.
I'm not suggesting you should go out and
do anything crazy with this list, but
these were the companies which met all
three characteristics. If you take
CrowdStrike, it's a tough one for me,
right?
You have no governance.
So, basically, you have to start with
that. That their debt ratio was 0.82%.
Cost of capital of 10.99%, not
surprising, it's riskier. The return on
capital is high, but I would add a
qualifier. This is a company which is a
technology company. What you see as
invested capital might not reflect the
true invested capital, so that number
might be overstated. But, basically,
that's still higher than the cost of
capital. The optimal debt ratio, at
least according to this analysis, and I
will
I put, you know, some quotes around it.
It looks under leveraged, and it had
positive free cash flow to equity, and
return nothing.
And it came
said I would love to see that number
three. It's basically valued at about
eight, nine times
the value. But, if that is true, this is
your deal of a century, right? It's
meeting every single criteria.
So, if you're the CrowdStrike person, I
would like to talk to you.
Maybe after this is nothing to do with
your project because, you know, it is
not a company I would expect to see on
the top of the list. It's not the kind
of company that should make these
screens.
So, as I said, it's caveat emptor. So,
this is basically what you told me were
your quadruples. So, maybe some
companies in the list would be a good
place for you to say, "Okay, I want to
take a closer look at this company
to see if it meets all of my criteria."
So, it took us a while.
We're back to the page we started.
This is all of corporate finance, right?
We've spent the entire class on this
page.
The investment principle basically says
go out and take investments that earn a
return greater than the hurdle rate.
Return should be based on cash flows,
and the hurdle rate should reflect the
risk of the investment and the mix of
debt and equity you use.
The financing principle says find a mix
of debt and equity that minimizes your
hurdle rate
and match your debt up to your assets.
The dividend principle basically says if
you can't find investments make your
return on make your cost of capital,
give the cash back, and whether you do
it in the form of dividends or buybacks,
I'm I'm agnostic. It depends on who your
shareholders are. In doing all of this,
you're trying to maximize your value as
a business.
So, here are some parting thoughts
which go back to what I said the initial
objectives for this class were. Remember
I called this a big picture class.
That was the big picture.
But, I would strongly encourage when
you're stuck in a problem to elevate,
take a look at the big picture. Cuz too
often in corporate finance and
investing, we get stuck on some small
piece of corporate finance. We get
obsessed with it. Getting the cost of
debt right to the fourth decimal point.
And if you step back and said, "In the
larger scheme of things, does it really
matter?" And the answer is no,
you can let it go. So, that's part of
what I hope you get out of this class is
capacity to look back and say, "Where
does this fit?" Many of you will be in
jobs where you're in a small slot of
this big picture.
And you think you're recreating the
world when, in fact, you're nudging the
world one way or the other. Recognizing
what you do and where it fits in the big
picture will make you better whatever
you're doing, whether you're a
consultant, a banker, you know, or
working in a company. Think about what
is it that we do.
Second,
it's an applied class. Everything we
did, I tried to apply.
In the process, did I have to bend some
rules? Absolutely.
I'm not a purist. I'm a pragmatist.
If you made a big deal about betas and
you don't like them, I'll let it go.
It's just a small piece to me of the big
picture.
Don't
try to defend models.
Cuz models are just, you know, measures
of what people try to do by assuming
things. So, if you need to bend
something to apply it,
go ahead and do it. The Now, what the
one thing that I tried to get you out of
during this project was getting stuck.
Cuz many of you at some point in time
got to a point and said, "I'm stuck."
You will be stuck whatever you choose to
do, wherever you choose to do it. You'll
have to figure out a way to get past
that because you stay stuck,
the rest will not get done.
And finally, I did try to promise, but I
won't go back there and said corporate
finance could be fun, and this might not
be the point to say that because you
don't feel it's that much fun after
spending a a long night
on your project.
But, one of my favorite books is this
book called Aha! Insight. It was written
by this guy who used to write puzzles
for the Scientific American.
And Aha! Insight is about sometimes
seeing a phenomenon and connecting it
with some other question in your mind
that you always wondered what the answer
was to, and you connect it to.
What I want you to do is look for those
moments, basically, where you see
something happening and say, "Aha!"
Because you got the framework to think
through these problems.
So, rather than look for the answer,
kind of figure it out yourself because
that's really going to be what what what
kind of separates
So, I I final reminder, there is a CFE
for this class you got to fill out. You
know why I'm reminding you of it?
Because we don't fill out the CFE.
You know what the CFE is, right?
The course evaluation. I
I think it's called CFE.
It's like eight questions, and they're
all highly correlated, so I don't know
why they just mark it one question and
say, "What do you think?" No. But,
they used to have 21. I was in the
committee and said, "Nobody has the time
to answer 21 questions in finals week."
You know why you you need to fill out
the course evaluations as an MBA?
Cuz if you don't fill them out, you
can't get a grade. And if you And this
is purely selfish. If you If you can't
look up your grade, guess who you email?
Me. So, I'm trying to save myself the
trouble of saying, "For God's sakes, go
fill the CFE out
because then you're not emailing me
saying, 'I didn't fill out the CFE. I
can't find my grade. Can you send me
your grade?'" So, I think you got a
three-day window. Do it now when you're
feeling
pissed off about your pro I don't really
care what you do. Just get it done,
right? So, thank you very much, and I
and I want to again, you know, if you
can pass this on to the first years
coming in, I will not be teaching
valuation next year.
And I gave you my reason because I'm
taking a sabbatical to look after my
daughter's baby. So, I'll be changing a
lot of diapers,
of feeding. So, this won't be top of my
list, but I'll be back, God willing,
spring of 2027
to teach valuation again.
Any of you planning to stay around for
two extra years?
I need TAs for that class. This is going
to be a tough semester for spring of
2027 to get TAs. So, if any of you
decide to fail next year, let me know
because I will call you on call upon you
as a TA. But, thank you very much for uh
hanging in there and putting in all the
work you did.
A reminder again that your final exam
is due on
for that
for your job in the ratings
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you for an
excellent class.